Yes. Now you don't need to say that so i'll
start again. Never. If you don't worry
about it. I'm talking to mr.
Jack macrae who worked on the
sydney harbour bridge as
a concrete. Will you tell us about
those years. Mr macrae yes. I
arrived in sydney in april
1927 and immediately i
hit sydney that day and made my way down
to the harbor. And with the intention of
finding out where the harbor
bridge site was. And this was done
by medium of the tram down during the
street. And when i got down to do us
a point there was certainly
a great deal of activity going on there.
One of the first things i did was to
interview the foreman.
Doors print with the
intention of getting employment. Do
you members name do you. Yes it was.
The foreman's name the general foreman
whose correct total it was was
mr harry sinclair. And i asked him for
employment and he said to me. Can you climb
. You know i said yes and
soon after that he said to me
you can start tomorrow morning
and what did you get first
a matter of fact i got the job that
i was on for five years. Packing
concrete exactly what does the job of pack
a cockpit how did you go about
it. Well packing terror is
a piece of steel about five eighths
of an inch diameter with a spade like
a small spade like part on
one end of it and a ring for
a handle on the other and this was to
to agitate concrete and to make sure
that when the when the forms
etc were stripped that
a good finish was obtained so that
takes the place of what is now
a vibrator. Yes that is so
that takes the place of
a vibrate. So you were ramming the concrete
down all the time into their mind does
that's an awful lot of concrete. That is
so you do you member any incidents that
happened while you were working down there.
Did you start with the foundations in
the first place. When i arrived there
you know probable 1927 the pilings were
about twenty five to thirty feet in height
from the ground. So the foundations had
been built had skew backs as they used to
call them have been built and they were
up so far and you end up from there with
them. That is so what about the the
placing of the of the granite how did
they do that with the country. Well each
course of granite was of course
numbered and was placed in position by
a stone mason who was assisted
by a laborer and also
a dogman the. The granite blocks
were hoisted into position by
a seven ton crane on each
pylon and after after the
the the stones granite themselves
were laid the concrete was
filled in behind. And of course behind
that again was the concrete pile in it. So
yes i understand. Well i understand there
at one stage they ran out of stones and
had to carry on with the concreting i don't
remember that. And do you remember any
. Any accidents or any tragic incidents.
Here so can the first accident that i
remember was in nineteen
twenty seven or twenty eight
a chap but the name of tom the key and was
killed on the doors point side between
the pile and the next pier.
Unfortunately here he was
on
a scaffold and the chain
operating this block became
entangled in his leg and and
the scaffolding capsized and
tom was was falling falling to the ground.
I went out to his funeral with
a lot more at botany
cemetery that. Another near
another and near accident was around
about 1930 dogman but the name of percy
young was riding one of these pieces of
granite up very high about 200 feet i
should say off the ground when the
crane driver and the man himself.
Happened to have
a lapse and the. The chain the chain.
I'm sorry i'm getting
on next to the. About
200 feet. The train driver had misread the
the mark on his cable and the the
of the block on the crane was pulled
through the geneva wheel at the top of
the tube and the. Dogman percy young
was left hanging there with his elbow only
a few inches from through being dragged
from being dragged through this journey
where all the piece of granite that he was
standing on crashed to the ground and he
was left there dangling in
mid-air. The driver got such
a shock that he immediately went and gave
in his notice. Do you know what his name
was no i can't remember the crane driver's
name. He was driving the well and the
twenty five ton crane that. The
alarm was raised. Of course and
very very soon riggers came to the rescue
and another train driver came along
and move the train job over to where this
man could be landed in safety. Yes it's
a nasty incident to anything happen to you
any incidents that happened to you. The
only thing that happened to me was i got
a blow on the head. Rivet fell on
my head and. That was around about
1931. And i remember going chap
took me up to sydney hospital and
five stitches were put into my head. There's
no safety helmets in those days. No
everybody wore either
a cap or so soft hat. Yes. Do you remember
any amusing instance when you when
you working on the bridge.
Well one. One when
there was three of us generally working
together and this concrete taking it was
alec and. And scotsman young scotsman
and a chap called jeremy aziz who was
a lebanese. And one day i said oh
look there it goes there goes and
we looked and said to him what joe what are
you talking about he said there it goes
there it goes and he said i said
what is it and he said it's
it's
a bubble off my tongue.
Here amber you member
lunch at the foundations. Here
so i can remember the lunch
hours. We used to knock off at
six minutes to twelve and resume
a trove thirty six pm and the whistle in
those days. Doorman long had acquired
the syrah and from the first h m
a sydney. And it was. Tremendous
sound when it went off and
the first blast at six ministers
to twelve was one blast only
but
a twelve thirty six. When the
resumption of work commenced. The. The
men used to blow it to long blasts on
their on this hooters. Do you member.
What do you say happened during lunch.
Did your sit down being too tired or did
people used to skylight youngsters used
to skylark to know when in fact the
we had
a change. Room and doors point where you
could sit down and in no days the conditions
were somewhat trimeter for us
far as making tea. There was
a big cup full of boiling water ready
for team making but afterwards as soon
soon as the lunch was eaten genuine
cards were played for money.
Generally small stakes for poker and no
crown anchor of that side oh no no. Crown
and anchor where we were only
only the cards. Yes ever in the
workshop they supply crown anchor if they
only didn't know about. When you're at do
it's point you're the first person i've
interviewed who who knows what. Well what
went down around point do you remember the
carpenters workshop. Yes i do remember
the carpenters workshop i remember all the
carpenters to form and carbon i missed
out there glenny who now lives who now
lives who now lives that panini you. And
also the other carpenters there were about
six in number and they like myself saw
the whole job through. So you started
in in what year was it 1927 i started
that was very early yet. And you finished.
What do you nineteen. Thirty two. Yes.
Thirty two. But you you finished
up before the bridge was finished
a fortnight before. Do you remember
anything else about the working conditions
around those point. Yes i do remember the
working conditions around ground about
doors point. We we had in my case
we were successful in
getting when we got up
a certain height which i think was
over fifty feet. We were successful in
approaching the management and we were
three of us were allowed ten minutes
changing time or cleaning
time and this was
a ten minutes to five ten to minister five
every day. Did you after you finish the
pylon did you go on the deck or not.
No i didn't go on any further work. No
concreting. And that 1932
and you were laid off
. Do you remember the opening of the bridge
or yes i remember the opening very well
. And i was up and york street with my wife
hadn't been married very long and then
and we we were up in new york
street and i was some half
a mile. I suppose from the actual ceremonies
at that. So you know you were you
couldn't get anywhere near the actual
ceremony. Well no i wasn't i would say hours
down the scotch church or somewhere down
the part of york street. Did you walk over
the bridge after it was over. Yeah. Yes i
walked over over the bridge after it was
a month
a great crowd that was there that day and
do you were out of work then yes i was
out of work after after that. Yes. For some
considerable time. Do you get the dole
. Yes i did eventually but you mean
eventually. Oh that would be about six months
after the opening after i became out of
work. Why didn't you get the dole for six
months. Well i had
a little bit of money in the bank and in
those days the state government and the
people that control the social services
made sure that you had to use up all your
own money first before you could be become
an eligible for any assistance. What
about you if you had any assets if you had
a house to what about that. Well i you
know in those days i didn't say in any
properties so but i know very well the
people that did they had to sell their
houses first before they could get anything
or furniture to get in the thing. And
the assistance from the state government
when you got the dole did you get coupons
or was it rations or what it was
a coupon and in this case it amounted
to nine shillings california tonight.
And what about cooking money did you get
anything for the meter. No we didn't get
anything like that. You know some people
reckon that they got five shillings for
the meat i suppose that was married with
children. Ah well that's something that i
don't know really. And how do
you pay the rent. Well i had to
put on some different things that i had
from time to time and that was the way that
i managed to pay the rent of the del
inspector steer. Yes i remember dale and
spectres but i never met any of them
personally and there never had cause to have
a go at you know. Naturally i was
a delicate for that one of the unions at
the bridge and that made me very. Class
conscious and no. Could you tell us about
union meetings to about the unionism on
the bridge. Yes there was
a good union feeling amongst the people
that i mean that i represented and. We
which union was that was
that the w this was the
a stallion worker's union yes. And at that
time of course they weren't affiliated
with the trades and labour council and we
had to that is the other delegates and
myself we had to do
things of our own bout to
a great extent. And at the same
time we. I did have to approach the
management on one occasion when one of
our chaps. Allegedly victimized and
after taking three fellow workers and
also the secretary of the union. We
interviewed mr.
Martin and we were successful in getting
this. Work at reinstated and i had
a very good relationship with mr.
James knew who was the works of the field
manager and often after five o'clock of
a night time he would speak
with me and. He even used to
revise me sometimes how to go about things.
You remember him personally. Do you did
you meet him afterwards. Yes i
had a good relationship with mr.
James muir and i could say that i was
a personal friend of hers. So what with
the relations with him and the union that
they were good with their doormen long and
the and the unions. Yes there was very
little friction from our point of view
and i think the incident that i just
mentioned was about the only serious one
that i had to approach the management
about did you have anything to do with the
negotiations between the government. I
understand that there was
a rise and fall of wages contact so
consequently the government had to pay the
extra if you was increases in pay. And when
the government labor government changed
i remember from the records
that the government went back
on the agreement but it already been made
at one stage. And there were arguments do
you were you involved in that at all. No i
wasn't involved in any negotiations like
that but i do remember the
time that you speak of but
it went down to arbitration in melbourne.
I think yes i believe you're right that
would be the federal arbitration court
of course i looked up the yes the
arbitration court proceedings down in
melbourne in. Bradfield actually spoke on
behalf against the government on behalf
of the men i was rather surprised to see
there's nothing happened to him about
it. Well you were job delicate
. You didn't get that far up in negotiations.
You know of the only time that i ever
. I think
a couple of times i went to this state
conciliation court when we were going. For
increased height money and on two occasions
i think and also one time the dogman
were after increases and i
went up to the state can
do you member jim campbell. Yes i do
remember jim campbell and he also was
a personal friend of mine who came
from liverpool in england and he was
a leading regular there and he was in charge
of about eight to ten riggers. And he
was also of course. In mr james knew
of confidence and off and jim used to
relay information that mr.
Muir made to me. And i can say that i had
a fairly close relationship with
jim campbell. And unfortunately
a few weeks before the bridges opened
he was accidentally killed and
it was very sad to. First
such a fine man and he was
a rugged type of individual himself to
be taken when the reach was just about
due for completion you member what happened.
Yes i remember what happened. He was
to he was in charge of the taking
down the needles as they were called
these girders that was sticking out of the
top of each pylon that had been used to
swing the disc falls down for the leading
down of the parlance by by an army of
laborers and. He was
shifting the heavy. Oregon.
Around at the top of the pile and
when when the thing skidded and
and. Struck jim and he was
catapulted over the side
and. He on the for on his for he was.
He intercepted. One of the steel standards
and then eventually for fell to the
ground and because his body was much
mutilated and it was very very sad
. Yes. Do you remember the crane
drivers dear. Yes i do remember the
train drivers fairly well
there was mr. Samuel. Mr.
Bob kline the hasty brothers didn't know
them so well and then another one called
fred rivals. I also knew
john king. He was the main
train driver on the doors
point side and also
a new zealand new zealander called on
the melton's point side. We knew him as
big wilkie he also had a brother was
a driver on the one of the minor cranes
on the creeper. I also remember jack far.
He was an englishman. He was he
was on the point side the train.
Immediately before his
employment at sydney he was
a train driver on the state theatre
in market street sydney and he was
a typical. Little englishman
we used to call him
. And i just wish to call
him the british bulldog.
Sam where in 1931 he was good enough
to become the best man at my wedding
. Later in the a few weeks after
that i was presented with
a silver tea service by the
workers at this point. And.
Love cline he was one of the other member
drivers to do is point he lived at
marrickville and. After the bridges
open we used to meet at. G.